pulluler il commettrait un suicide
collectif
ces petits mammifères ce sont les
limites comme ils viennent d'être
mentionné ces lemmings sont ceux de
petits rongeurs dont il est peut-être
entendu parler en association avec des
mouvements de masse ou alors les
amateurs de jeux vidéo les connaissent
comme disons un jeu vidéo qui simule
certains comportements associés à ces
lemmings pour nous autre biologiste
on avait bien sûr nos doutes quant à la
réalité d'un suicide collectif chez des
animaux surtout en masse voilà comment
l'interprète le caricaturiste gary
larson vous voyez des lemmings qui se
précipitent vers la mer tous vont mourir
avec une exception celui qui va
perpétuer l'espèce c'est celui qui sera
équipé de bouée de sauvetage
bref pour nous autres donc on a cherché
en vain aussi dans la littérature des
documents présentant ses suscite
mais on pourra chercher encore longtemps
on n'en trouve pas en tout cas ça nous a
motivés pour mettre en place à un projet
à long terme qui permettra de vous
accompagner donc vous ma compagne aurait
ce soir au gré de landes où nous sommes
nous partons chaque été depuis 30 ans
pour étudier ces lemmings c'est les
mines dont le territoire comporte
essentiellement les zones hostiles qui
cerne l'océan arctique
vous avez ici la scandinavie la sibérie
vous en trouvez en alaska
dans leur canadien et en os grenland ils
sont confinés dans la partie nord-est et
vous voyez ici notre site d'études donc
à plus de mille kilomètres au nord de
l'islande
l'habitat des lemmings en été ça
rappelle un peu les zone sommitale des
ipod au dessus de 2000 mètres donc c'est
des habitats habilitation très rabougri
ici une prise de vue de mi juillet noté
la présence en cours de chant de neige
d'autres fonte et surtout d'une
végétation très rare mais c'est sa
l'habitat du lemmings pendant le cours
était article l'été arctique
il dure en moyenne deux à trois mois
mais pour le lemming son habitat
principal c'est en fait libère la
particularité des lemmings c'est de
vivre pendant neuf mois sous le manteau
neigeux
c'est là qu'ils se reproduisent et c'est
vraiment paradoxal de savoir que dans
des conditions si extrêmes avec en hiver
des températures jusqu'à -40 le lemming
reste actif contrairement à l'eau
marmotte qui ici vont hiberner
mais le les mines restent actifs sous la
neige est donc cet environnement le
lemming le partage avec d'autres espèces
on va voir lesquels parmi les herbivores
tank le lemming c'est un herbivore c'est
un rongeur il est un peu en parenté avec
nos campagnes hall et dans ces milieux
donc ici on le voit consommant des
chatons de sol un
mais ils partagent cet habitat avec
aussi des boeufs musqués et du lièvre
arctique
accessoirement aussi avec des lagopède
aînés donc nous avons une communauté de
d'herbivores mais dans ces milieux quand
on parle d'herbivores ya peut-être aussi
des prédateurs qui s'en nourrissent
allons voir lesquels donc les prédateurs
qui
friand de delémont c'est en particulier
les remises que vous avez aussi vous
trouvez ici dans le dur hein vous avez
le renard polaire accessoirement aussi
le loup blanc et surtout la chouette
dainese donc la chouette des neiges et
l'hermine sont des prédateurs très
spécialisés sur le lemming en l'absence
de lemmings vous n'avez ni hermine vous
n'avez ni chouette des neiges et donc
c'est un peu ces interactions qu'on
étudie sur place vous avez ici la chaîne
alimentaire
vous voyez tous ceux qui sont dépendants
des lemmings et c'est en étudiant ces
interactions
donc on s'est dit qu'on a peut-être une
chance d'élucider ces cycles de lemmings
mener des recherches en milieu arctique
c'est d'abord un grand défi logistique
nous travaillons dans une zone des plus
reculés du monde
il s'agit du plus grand parc national le
parc national du nord-est du groenland y
fait une fois et demie la surface la
france il ya moins de personnes que dans
une rangée ce soir ici donc le père
juste le personnel des bases et donc
l'accès forcément il n'y a pas de deux
lignes aériennes qui desservent donc il
faut tout arranger soi même c'est donc
un grand défi logistique pour y accéder
et aussi pour y mener les recherches en
été surtout manque de confort on arrive
sur place au mois de juin c'est encore
en léger et la fonte intervient lors la
fonte des neiges généralement vers la
fin du mois de juin qui dégage alors la
toundra et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
met en place nous suivi et c'est suivi
consiste essentiellement en une méthode
indirecte c'est à dire on veut savoir
comment évolue l'évolution
population de lemmings d'une année à
l'autre donc bien sûr on en capturant
n'était qu' on équipe aussi de petites
mini balises mais là la proche principal
c'est qu'on va compter leurs nids divers
ils vivent en hiver sous la neige et
c'est là qu'ils se reproduisent ils
peuvent se reproduire jusqu'à y avoir
jusqu'à 5 portes et en l'espace d'une à
l'hiver vous rendez compte du potentiel
de reproduction et c'est surtout les
nids ici à droite qui sont intéressants
pour nous puisqu'il nous révèle que ce
n' y ont été présentés par l'hermine
d'hermine c'est le seul prédateur
susceptibles de les chasser en hiver
sous la neige et l'hermine alors dès
qu'elle repère en idées me va récupérer
les poils de ces trois pour en faire son
propre sac de couchage et c'est pour
nous une indication sur la présence d
hermine en hiver donc c'est souvent un
travail très fastidieux de documenter la
présence de tous est ni divers on en
compte jusqu'à 4000 les années tic
donc effectivement ça pullule tous les
quatre ans ou cinq ans et puis après on
en voit presque plus on descend à moins
de 50 ni divers et donc on essaye aussi
de modéliser les interactions donc on va
savoir combien de lemmings sont
consommés par chaque prédateur par
exemple des chouettes des neiges peuvent
en consommer jusqu'à une vingtaine par
jour et vous voyez l'impact que cela
peut avoir sur une population mais aussi
les renards les l'abbé les hermines
interviennent et donc on a pu modéliser
toutes ces interactions et qu'on a
publié d'ailleurs et qui montre bien que
c'est la relation avec l'hermine qui est
fondamental dans le déterminisme de ces
cycles c'est à dire tous les 4-5 ans
donc on a un pic de lemmings et les
hermines réalise pratiquement avec une
année de retard puisque on s'imagine les
lemmings peuvent avoir cinq portées par
hiver donc partir de zéro à presque 100
alors que l'est
mais l'est elle est handicapée mais dès
lors qu'elles puissent se reproduire
elle va contribuer à faire effondrer les
effectifs des lemmings à un aspect donc
on continue ce monitoring donc c'est
cette étude sur le long terme ça fait
maintenant trente ans nous avons des
observations et ce qui frappe c'est
effectivement l'absence les 15 premières
années on avait les jolies fluctuations
qui s'estompe à partir de verre vers
2011 initialement n'avait pas
d'explication encore très probante mais
d'évidence les changements de
l'enneigement qu'on connaît aussi ici
dans les alpes peuvent être incriminé
dans ce phénomène
il reste donc on sait aussi que
l'arctique est aux premières loges du
changement climatique qui est beaucoup
plus intense que dans nos régions
tempérées
alors justement concernant les effets
des changements climatiques est un autre
aspect où on s'en rend compte dans notre
quotidien que vraiment les conditions
changent
c'est en observant cette statistique
on a enregistré toutes les rencontres
avec des ours berne puisque notre
campement est juste en bord de côte et
c'est pas rare de voir alors les ours
blancs qui débarque sur la terre ferme
dans la statistique vous voyez en bleu
c'est les ours encore sur la banquise en
brens et les ours qui sont sur la plage
et envers les ours loin à l'intérieur
des terres on n'attend pas du tout à en
rencontrer
et justement vous voyez que aussi vers
l'an 2000 2002 pratiquement du jour au
lendemain on avait des ours
régulièrement alors qu'antérieurement
look ne posait jamais problème est que
c'est là pour documenter un peu le
quotidien donc un où cela qu'ils
vérifient notre station météo peut-être
qu'ils le délit fier
si le changement climatique est bien
indiquée de très nombreuses reprises
l'otan ont été lacérés donc c'est
vraiment aussi un défi au niveau de la
sécurité
et vous voyez notre de trappeurs et
l'ours qui l'a éventré à de très
nombreuses reprises
donc on est très très souvent exposés à
des visites d'ours
allez donc on doit prendre des mesures
en conséquence et vraiment ça fait
partie maintenant notre quotidien et
justement donc pour les ours aussi c'est
un défi pour savoir s'ils vont pouvoir
survivre puisque ils sont désormais
privés de banquise pendant une plus
longue période et dont ils viennent sur
la terre ferme est donc pour nous aussi
c'est un challenge est en fait donc pour
conclure peut dire si les lemmings en
fait il n'ya pas de celui-ci mais en
tout cas la réalité le l'arctique et 20
ans aux prises du changement climatique
très très net